amid the fields of northern Italy this
is the area where Europe's outbreak of
coronavirus seems to have started here
ten towns are in quarantine you need
special permission to get in or out as
we filmed two ambulances came out of
this so-called red zone the paramedics
and this one wearing full-body
protective suits but before these
roadblocks and controls were put in
place who knows how many people had been
in and out of these towns and where they
dispersed to especially in Europe where
such a value is put on free movement of
people so we're going to take a trip
starting here to see how easy it is to
drive across Europe from the quarantine
area we head Northwest joining traffic
from across Europe the consonance
Schengen rules are designed to ease the
movement of goods and people if you fly
in or out of Italy on a plane you're met
with massed officials wildung
thermometers but if you use a motorway
nobody notices you three hours after we
left the roadblock we have now left
Italy and entered France and nobody's
asked where we've been or asked to check
our identity now Europe prides itself on
its open invisible borders but as
coronavirus spreads there are bound to
be those who asked for more scrutiny and
more checks plenty of the people on the
roads here are tourists heading to
Europe's busiest winter sport
destinations
this is shaman II with five million
visitors every year and this is the
perfect example of the problem that
Europe now faces just a relatively short
drive from towns that are quarantined
because of coronavirus to get a resort
like this people come here from all over
the world they mix together in close
proximity and then they go home again
among the skiers some nerves but also
plenty of shrugs the snowy mountain Cove
at 19 does still a long way
I worry a lot but I try to you know
travel with their masks and be careful
no I want to make sure that we kind of
assist with Public Health efforts to
avoid a spread but I don't feel
personally back on the road and into
Switzerland still no medical checks or
screening we've driven from the
quarantine zone in Italy all the way to
the place leading the global fight
against coronavirus the lesson is that
every country has to be ready every
country has to invest heavily in their
health systems so whenever virus comes
they can quickly detector test and
provide health care for those who are
sick delegations that come here from
around the world to seek advice visitors
today
included the former health secretary who
gave us this warning but I think the
truth is that Schengen or no Schengen we
are in such a globalized world as you
can see by the way it's spread that
everyone has to take precautions even
though the mortality rate of one to
three percent sounds low if millions and
millions of people get this far that is
a loss of deaths and so that's why we
have to prepare for worst-case scenarios
for the moment Europe's response has
been deliberately calm and measured but
under the surface there is anxiety
nobody knows what will happen next
Adam Parsons Sky News Geneva